[Musique]
dimanche 8h30 gare de l'est à paris
autour d'une locomotive une foule
insolite qui ressemble un petit peu à
celle des trains de plaisir d'autrefois
clic clac la photo du siècle
silence moteur on tourne comme à la télé
le film qui moralise race grand moment
germaine empêche le gaz de mettre ses
doigts dans les yeux du chien denise où
es tu me les pellicules josette passe
mal panier à provisions et tout ça pour
elle pour cette locomotive qui a
transporté nos grands parents et nos
arrière-grands-parents et dont c'est
aujourd'hui le dernier voyage
spécial
il est monté en voiture et maintenir les
portières fermées ces doubles
l'amicale des anciens mécaniciens et
chauffeurs des amis de la traction
vapeur ainsi que la sncf vous souhaite
un bon voyage
attention fumer
là 230g matricule 353 va prendre le
départ
voilà accroupis sur les rails face à la
locomotive
qui arrive
notre cameraman risque sa vie le monstre
s'approche si près qu'il a juste le
temps de souffler sur le remblai en
sauvant le matériel d'abord comme il se
doit
[Musique]
et l'épopée commence paris versailles en
over parcours inoubliable voyage grisant
qui nous permettra de découvrir les
secrets de beauté des hlm de la grande
ceinture iceberg coloré de rose devait
reparler de bleu lavande planté au
milieu des cheminées des usines et des
hangars à ferraille
et ce décor rentable rêveuses et
mélancoliques notre 230 g qui
distraitement la tête dans un nuage de
vapeur secousses et 78 kg de fer et
d'acier car nous la verrons plus ce
matin à l'aube comme les condamner pour
la sortie de la prison l'entreprise de
noisy-le-sec votre pouvoir rejeter
courage et voyez comme il en a même
[Musique]
monsieur andré adro en tant que
président de l'amicale des anciens de la
traction à vapeur ça doit vous faire une
certaine peine quand même ce cet ultime
voyage de cette sympathique locomotive
bien sûr bien sûr ça fait d'abord
de la peine parce que comme vous dites
c'est le dernier est ce que ça vaut une
locomotive comme ça actuellement il ya
une 231 qui est en cours de rachat ça
coûte
quatre-vingt mille francs environ il
s'agit là d'une 230 g oui elle est née
quand locomotive qu'est né dans les
années les fins si vous voulez elle
était exploitée sur le perron à
l'origine une suite leur dû passer sur
la sncf et puis
mise ensuite retiré de sa population
pourrait être
pour être utilisé dans des trains
spéciaux comme celui là la remplacer la
grande tonnes ont été utilisées
précédemment ceo c'est-à-dire paris
orléans fait ça c'est ça c'est ça
monsieur philippe garnier vous êtes-vous
l'organisateur de ce voyage j'aurais
tout d'abord nous demander si cette de
gasquet était vraiment réglementaire
très bien ce n'est pas une casquette
français c'est une casquette espagnol
parce que je suis collectionneur de
casquettes et c'est la seule casquette
de ma collection qu'un tour de taille de
58 alors c'est la seule que je pouvais
mais c'est la seule raison elle est
utilisée sur les chemins de fer à voie
étroite espagnol exploité par l'état qui
circulent sur le nord de l'espagne l'an
de la pohdh cantabrique hendaye bilbao
50 dr gijon piedoux el ferrol el khaoudi
ion à cesson et aux tee-shirts autrement
que le plus si robinson ou versailles on
est en train de parcourir nous il ya
comment s'est organisé ce voyage quand
on organise un voyage il faut prendre
évidemment contact avec la sncf se
décider pour un parcours le type de
locaux qu'est ce que l'on désire et le
type de voiture décidé d arrêt avec les
sief
donner aux desiderata et ensuite on
discutent pour savoir si telle chose est
possible ou ne l'est pas non je ne vous
cacherai pas pour avoir ces voitures
armistice dans lequel nous sommes en ce
moment nous avons quand même fort mal de
difficultés parce que ça fait
quatre ans qu'elles n'ont pas roulé
et garder spécialement mais ces wagons
d'où vient-il ces voitures ne sont pas
gardés à paris elles viennent de metz et
de châlons sur marne il est dommage que
des voitures insiste éric de ce type ne
soit pas garer à paris parce que c'est
évidemment à laquelle serait la pente
d'utilisation alors aujourd'hui nous
allons jusqu'à versailles où nous allons
nous sommes partis vers 9h ce matin on
va arriver à versailles vers midi c'est
cesser cela alors il ya un arrêt d'une
heure quarante à versailles nous en
repartons à 13h41 pour revenir à paris
est nommé via la partie nord puisque ce
matin nous utilisons la partie sud via
valenton et massy l'ours l'orne façon
via saint saint germain argenteuil
aulnay et gardant
[Musique]
et nous arrivons à massy-palaiseau
jusque sur une voie de garage pour une
cérémonie rarissime de nos jours le
ravitaillement en eau d'une locomotive
de 130 g
[Musique]
et
monsieur celle rivette et le chef
mécanicien responsable du dernier voyage
de 7 230 quelle impression ça vous fait
ça fera pas appel des jeunes venaient à
peine de poser un peu plus longtemps
vous conduisez des locomotives à
46 qu'est ce que je ferais comme voyage
comme tant de cohésion paris et chaumont
paris par le duc cela limitera jours et
puis après vous avez conduit les autres
sous le par après
convertir et laquelle des deux vous
préférez comme batteur ou la vapeur le
moteur électrique est parlée
la vapeur pendant l'enfance
la vapeur c'est quand même là vavi du
mécanisme en la vie n'est pas la même
non hannachi n'a pas peur tu as vu on a
vu aussi chevrier vous expliquer
l'opération qui se déroule en ce moment
ici à massy
sont les pompiers qui sont sales il ya
un avant plus gros hydraulique
maintenant à dia puma fils vapeur non la
région donc à chaque pas nous voulons un
voyage ce sont les pompiers qui nous
ravit tableau comme vous voyez comment
monsieur chevrier vous reste encore
combien de temps a passé
donc c'est vraiment un dernier voyage à
droit et marque
après ma foi après là est la question
la 230 g qui connut son heure de gloire
juste après la victoire de 14-18 alors
que rutilante 9 l effectuer son premier
voyage elle qui conduisit les premiers
vacanciers syndiqués au touquet à dieppe
à etretat ou à trouville nous ne la
verrons plus elle est condamnée au pire
des châtiments et sera des timbrés pour
une locomotive être des timbres et c'est
l'asile
puis la mort lente ou l'humiliation chez
un désosseur ferrailleurs un seul espoir
le musée mais tout le monde n'est pas la
joconde
le comique
nous arrivons à versailles chantiers
1h40 d'arrêt point final ou
d'interrogation que deviendra la 230 g
vous le saurez en suivant sur antenne 2
le prochain épisode des malheurs d'une
locomotive
[Musique]